madame la ministre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue au sein de cette délégation
aux droits des femmes du sénat qui vous
entends pour la première fois depuis la
formation du gouvernement d'elisabeth
rome votre nomination au gouvernement a
suscité au sein de notre délégation
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé la preuve avec
la présence nombreuse des sénatrices et
sénateurs hier soir à votre ministère et
nous fûmes nous étions même à l'heure
le sénat a envahie envahi votre
ministère à l'heure je ne doute pas que
nous trouverons en vous une
interlocutrice engagés et disponibles
pour défendre à nos côtés les droits des
femmes votre parcours et vos engagements
passés sont en effet la preuve de votre
des nouveaux vous ment anciens à cette
cause notamment en tant que magistrate
très investie dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et en tant
que haute fonctionnaire chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
au sein du ministère de la justice vous
aviez d'ailleurs été nommé dans le cadre
du grenelle des violences conjugales par
la garde des sceaux de l'époque nicole
belloubet bilotte des actions de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et est à l'origine de nombreuses
propositions prônant une approche et un
traitement particulier de ces violences
sont constitués à proprement parler une
présentation de votre feuille de route
officielle depuis officiel pardon
puisqu'elle est toujours en cours
d'élaboration
notre audition d'aujourd'hui doit être
l'occasion pour vous de nous présenter
les grands axes et les priorités de
votre action de ministre chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
en matière de lutte contre les
féminicides notamment quel bilan
tirez-vous près de trois ans après les
annonces gouvernementales de
l'application des mesures du grenelle de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes le nombre de féminicide recensés
en 2021 était de 113 contre 103 en 2020
le décompte du 16 juillet 2022 réalisé
par les associations fait état de 59
femmes tuées par leur compagnon ou
ex-compagnon
si des mesures concrètes ont été mises
en oeuvre distribution de téléphones
grave danger bracelet anti rapprochement
ordonnance de protection places
d'hébergement pour les femmes victimes
les stats mystique deux femmes tués dans
le cadre de violences conjugales
conjugale ne faiblisse malheureusement
pas doit-on y voir un échec de ces
mesures point d'interrogation
un défaut dormition dans leur conception
et leur application point
d'interrogation on pense bien évidemment
à l'exemple espagnol que vous citez
d'ailleurs madame namyst dans votre
livre intitulé liberté égalité survie
publié en 2020 l'espagne a pris ce film
il est là le niveau est bon si des
collègues souhaitent heures voilà c'est
d'un petite séquence publicitaire
donc l'espagne a pris ce phénomène à
bras le corps et a fait de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
une priorité politique et budgétaire
comme vous l'indiquez dans votre livre
l'espagne a bâti une politique
ambitieuse de lutte contre les violences
de genre objet depuis 2010 est d'impact
d'état votée à l'unanimité par les deux
assemblées parlementaires
avec plus de 200 mesures a décliné
pendant cinq ans comme on la france
pourrait-elle s'inspirer du modèle
espagnol selon vous madame la ministre
la situation des enfants exposés aux
violences intrafamiliales eux mêmes
victimes directes ou indirectes nous
préoccupe également particulièrement au
sein de la délégation comment les
protéger plus efficacement
comment les prendre en charge lorsqu'ils
ont été témoins de l'irréparable comment
reconnaître pleinement leur statut de
victimes des violences conjugales il
faut une fois pour toutes et quelles que
soient les circonstances
placer l'intérêt de l'enfant au dessus
du principe de coûts par an létalité de
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale et
des droits de visite et d'hébergement
par le parent violent une proposition de
loi en ce sens avait été déposé par nos
collègues députés sous l'ancienne
législature
quel avenir pour at-il lui être réservé
sur cette précédente mandature autre
sujet d'actualité
le droit à liv et g et son éventuelle
inscription dans la constitution
je regarde des sénatrices qui se sont
déjà engagés sur ce sujet à travers des
propositions loi
madame la ministre vous avez récemment
déclaré nous avant que la cour suprême
des etats unis a privé le droit à
l'avortement de cette protection
constitutionnelle il faut vraiment que
nous mettions le verrou de la
constitution pour garantir le droit
fondamental des femmes à disposer de
leur corps concrètement le gouvernement
est il prêt à déposer un projet de loi
constitutionnelle en ce sens
soutenez-vous la demande que par le
parlement européen d'inscription d'olive
et j'ai dans la charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne
enfin permettez moi de vous exposer
brièvement les sujets d'actualité de
notre délégation qui vous feront
peut-être réagir
nous avons beaucoup travaillé sur la
situation des femmes dans les
territoires ruraux et avons présentées
en début de session un rapport femmes et
ruralité en finir avec les zones
blanches de l'égalité dont vous avez pu
prendre connaissance évidemment ce
travail de plusieurs mois menée en
commun par huit co rapporteur a permis
de montrer que les inégalités entre les
femmes et des hommes sont décuplés dans
les territoires ruraux et se cumule avec
les inégalités territoriales
nous avons également consacrer nos
travaux cette année à l'industrie de la
pornographie et présentons notre rapport
sur ce thème en septembre notre constat
sur les violences envers les femmes
générés par cette industrie est alarmant
extrêmement grave d'ailleurs et nous
obliger à imposer dans le débat public
la question de la lutte contre les
violences pornographiques enfin nous
avons également publié un rapport sur le
bilan d'application des 10 ans de la loi
sauvadet apposant des obligations
paritaire dans la haute fonction
publique et je vois que notre collègue
martin fille elle qui est avec nous
présente rapporteur et dominique verrien
doit être également connectés en visio
ce sont les deux rapporteurs qui ont été
présentés leurs conclusions hier soir au
ministre guérini voilà j'en ai terminé
madame la ministre avec cette
présentation sans plus tarder je vous
laisse la parole est ensuite bien
entendu les collègues vous poseront les
questions qu'elle souhaite vous posez
cat de sénateurs aujourd'hui assez ça
donc je peux dire mesdames les
sénatrices bas je me réjouis de
m'exprimer face à vous aujourd'hui pour
la première fois depuis ma prise de
fonction
à ce ministère que j'aime bien qualifier
les mystères de combat tant les droits
des femmes ne sont jamais acquis tant il
demeure
fragile et qu'il mérite toute notre
vigilance
toute notre attention et toutes nos
forces
j'avais déjà pu l'observer lors de mes
précédentes fonctions de magistrat t2
haute fonctionnaire à l'égalité du
ministère de la justice je connais
l'importance et la qualité des travaux
de votre délégation et si comme vous
l'avez rappelé ma feuille de route n'est
pas encore totalement arrêtée
cette première rencontre est à la fois
l'occasion de vous écouter et de nouer
un premier dialogue alors à travers mes
propos liminaire je reviendrai sur le
bilan et coulées de ces cinq dernières
années et vous présenterai ma méthode
ainsi que les grands axes sur lesquels
je compte travailler avec vous
vous l'avez rappelé madame la présidente
dans votre jour alors c'est le sénateur
voilà
vous l'avez
la présidente vous l'avez rappelé dans
votre introduction
les finis les féminicides on sont encore
trop nombreux même si depuis 2020 on est
apte à une un chiffre un peu légèrement
en dessous de ski qui était celui
constaté auparavant
voilà ce chiffre est un chiffre morbide
et il nous faut absolument faire chuter
c'est vraiment le l'objet de tout ce
combat les ces violences faites aux
femmes viennent de loin demeure encore
la face sombre de notre société
néanmoins je pense qu'on peut dire que
depuis
plusieurs années et en particulier donc
au cours de ces cinq dernières
mais un véritable
difficilement s'est opérée avec une
véritable révolution culturelle
qu'il faut rappeler tout de même aussi
la forte mobilisation sociétales
sociales autour de ces violences faites
aux femmes autour des violences
conjugales car cette mobilisation
sociétal qui a provoqué aussi une forte
mobilisation politique l'organisation du
grenelle des violences conjugales en
2019 des lois nouvelles des dispositifs
nouveaux et on voit bien que comme
souvent d'ailleurs dans l'histoire des
droits des femmes notamment la prise de
conscience sociétal précède parfois la
prise de conscience politique et puis
ensuite vient la volonté politique et
puis toutes les mesures qui en découlent
et on voit que s'opère une véritable
révolution y compris dans les pratiques
des différents professionnels qui
doivent mettre en place ces nouvelles
mesures et il me semble aussi que les
victimes parlent davantage et que la
société les écoute enfin mais le chemin
évidemment vers l'éradication de ces
violences reste encore long
mais nous sommes je le crois devenus
intolérants face à cette intolérable
est ce ce combat contre les violences
faites aux femmes est un combat
éminemment républicain
il doit nécessiter une exigence de tous
les instants qui doit transcender tous
les clivages partisans
il me semble que le gouvernent que le
bilan du gouvernement et de la majorité
parlementaire en la matière et solide du
grenelle des violences conjugales que
vous avez évoquées ont découlé quatre
lois et 54 mesure dans 47 ans ont été
mises en oeuvre et quand je dis 54
j'inclus les huit mesures qui ont été
ajoutés suite au féminicide de mérignac
donc en juillet 2021 et qui donc mettre
un peu plus de temps à être mise en être
mises en oeuvre un enjeu érigée en
priorité par le président de la
république et qui dans la pratique a
mobilisé comme vous le savez tous les
ministères puisqu'ils touchent tous les
domaines de la vie quotidienne et je me
permets de préciser que j'ai réuni le 11
juillet un comité de suivi justement du
grand des mesures du grenelle des
violences conjugales avec l'ensemble des
directions représentant les différents
ministères pour vérifier l'état
d'avancement des mesures et je me
propose si vous en êtes d'accord de vous
en faire une restitution au mois de
septembre donc sous le format que vous
voudrez mais les voilà je pourrais vous
en faire une restitution détaillé
quasiment mesure par mesure comprend
voilà alors mieux protéger les victimes
c'est d'abord mieux accueillir leur
parole
157 mille policiers et gendarmes ont
reçu ainsi une formation pour un
meilleur accueil et accompagnement des
victimes
au niveau de la formation initiale 100 %
des élèves policiers et gendarmes sont
formés aujourd'hui à cette question au
moment au niveau de la formation
initiale en parallèle depuis le grenelle
416 intervenants sociaux en
commissariats et gendarmerie ont été
recrutés dont 40 dans les territoires
ultramarins
il s'agit désormais d'une priorité pour
nos forces de l'ordre
comme l'avait signifié le ministre de
l'intérieur le 1er août dernier les
plaintes pour violences conjugales
doivent être traitées avant tout les
autres il s'agit d'un véritable
changement culturel et d'une nécessité
absolue pour favoriser à la fois la
libération de la parole des victimes et
la sanction des auteurs par ailleurs le
contrôle de la détention et de
l'acquisition des armes a également été
renforcée dans le cadre du projet de loi
responsabilité pénale et sécurité
intérieure
dans ce sillon la france a été le
premier pays au monde à verbaliser le
harcèlement de rue en 2018 en créant la
fraction du trash sexiste
conformément aux engagements pris par le
président de la république à nice le 10
janvier dernier avec gérald darmanin
nous veillerons va doubler la présence
policière dans les transports en commun
ainsi qu'à triplé l'amande pour
harcèlement de rue
mieux protéger les victimes s'est aussi
déployée les dispositifs assurant leur
sécurité
sous l'impulsion du garde des sceaux
eric dupond moretti
nous avons vu un véritable essor de tous
les dispositifs de protection
je pourrais parler de l' ordonnance de
protection cette mesure civile que peut
prendre donc un juge aux affaires
familiales qui permet de prononcer
l'éloignement du conjoint violent et
dans le même temps d'organiser la vie de
la famille ont pu constater que nous
avons promis 554 ordonnance de
protection délivré en 2021 je rappelle
qu'en 2017 nous en avions 1308 et que
surtout ce qui est intéressant de
constater c'est que le taux
d'acceptation des demandes augmentent ce
qui montre aussi une plus grande
maîtrise de ce dispositif par les
différents professionnels par les
magistrats certes et jose affaires
familiales mais aussi par les barreaux
par les associations qui peuvent qui
présente aussi des requêtes certainement
mieux ficelé et qui permettent de donner
lieu aussi à des réponses positives
ainsi en 2021 nous avions à taux
d'acceptation de 67 8% et là des
derniers éléments que j'ai pu qu'on a pu
me communiqué nous avons un taux
d'acceptation qui est de l'ordre de
71,7 je crois oui 71 7%
s'agissant des téléphones grave danger
un dispositif qui a fait ses preuves
en 2021 il y a eu plus de 1500 1600
intervention des forces de l'ordre ce
qui montre que c'est autant d'agressions
éviter leur nombre a explosé on peut le
dire depuis 2010 est aujourd'hui il y à
4076 téléphone déployer ça veut dire
disponible sur l'ensemble du territoire
trois mille soixante dix attribués je
rappelle qu'en début début 2019 avant le
début du grenelle nous avions 300
téléphone attribués aujourd'hui
3070 l'objectif c'est d'avoir cinq mille
tgd déployés donc d'ici fin 2022
et aussi parce que protéger la victime
c'est aussi prévenir la récidive des
auteurs eh bien il faut prendre en
charge ceux ci
je dis souvent qu'il n'ya pas de
protection efficace des victimes sans
prévention de la récidive et prévenir la
récidive c'est prendre en charge la
violence des auteurs
présidente de cour d'assises j'ai vu
trop de trop nombreux accusés
comparaître avec des casiers judiciaires
qui comportait déjà des condamnations
pour des violences sur des campagnes
précédentes et en fait ce qui démontre
qu'il y a un problème de violence
intrinsèque finalement à ces personnes
en tout cas celles qui commettent
l'irréparable c'est à dire peut-être les
personnes les plus dangereuses dont il
faut vraiment traiter cette violence et
c'est dans cet esprit qu'ont été mis en
place trente centres de prise en charge
pour auteurs
dont qui existe maintenant donc depuis
2020 dans l'hexagone et outre mer afin
de lutter contre la récidive et prévenir
le passage à l'acte on peut il y à peu
près 6000 personnes qui ont été reçus
dans ces centres de prise en charge
notre arsenal législatif s'est également
renforcée grâce au concours du parlement
et je pense notamment à la proposition
de loi que vous avez porté madame la
présidente qui s'est traduite par un
allongement des délais de prescription
des crimes sexuels sur mineurs passer de
20 à 30 ans ainsi que par une
instauration d'une présomption de non
consentement pour les mineurs de moins
de 15 ans
à la suite de l'engagement du président
de la république au cours de la campagne
présidentielle
avec eric dupond moretti
nous travaillerons au développement
d'une justice
spécialisée pour le traitement des
violences intrafamiliales
mieux protéger les victimes
c'est aussi les mettre à l'abri parfois
dans l'urgence absolue
afin de mettre à l'abri les victimes de
violences le gouvernement a ouvert 1000
places d'hébergement d'urgence dédié en
2020 milles supplémentaires en 2021 avec
une revalorisation de 30% du coût pour
permettre un meilleur accompagnement
c'est à dire que il avait été souvent
souligné que les femmes pouvaient se
retrouver dans des foyers parfois mixtes
ou
il y avait des hommes plus ou moins
fréquentables qui pouvait justement se
trouvait à proximité
et donc là un effort
est vraiment accompli afin d'éviter cela
de la fin aussi d'accueillir plus
souvent les enfants avec elle est aussi
de mieux les accompagner sur le plan
social psychologique
2000 places seront à nouveau créé cette
année aujourd'hui donc le parc total est
dotée de 9000 38 places nous aurons eu
ainsi une augmentation de 80% de ce
nombre de places depuis 2010 est il
s'agit d'une hausse sans précédent
avec le ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires je travaillerai à renforcer
la répartition de ces places dans
l'hexagone j'ai conscience qu'il n'y a
pas forcément une répartition
vraiment et qui table encore sur tout
l'hexagone est aussi outre mer je
travaillerai aussi à mieux coordonner
les acteurs qui oeuvrent pour prendre en
charge les femmes qui ont quitté leur
domicile afin qu'elle puisse reprendre
une vie normale et ça c'est vraiment un
chantier que je souhaite ouvrir sur
lequel je souhaite travailler c'est à
dire que lorsque une femme obtient par
exemple une mesure de protection et bien
que la vie j'allais dire lui soit
facilité que l'autonomie lui son
autonomie soit favorisée par justement
un accompagnement plus resserrée sur le
plan social donc mises à sa disposition
mieux protéger les victimes
c'est également leur offrir des
structures d'accueil dédié à l'instar de
la maison des femmes de saint denis de
nombreuses structures travaillant de
manière holistique ont vu le jour ces
dernières années sous un même toit elles
permettent aux victimes de bénéficier de
l'expertisé d'une palette de
professionnels qui les accompagnent du
soin physique et psychologique à la
réinsertion professionnelle
pour moi aussi c'est cela c'est là à
châtier important avec le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention nous
travaillerons à renforcer ce maillage
territorial des maisons maison des
femmes
cette prise en charge sanitaire
psychologique et social des victimes est
absolument capital
mieux protéger les victimes
c'est aussi démultiplier les espaces de
libération de la parole la possibilité
de prise de plainte à l'hôpital ainsi
que le recueil de preuves sans dépôt de
plainte obligatoire préalable constitue
dès lors des avancées à la fois
extrêmement concrètes et significatives
ainsi
3363 examens ont été réalisés lors du
premier semestre 2022 dans le cadre du
recueil 100 plaintes soit une
augmentation de 40% par rapport à l'an
dernier sur la même période
c'est très important parce que nous
savons tout c'est tout ce que parfois
les victimes donc vont j'allais dire
consulter un médecin a effectué un
prélèvement éventuelle mais ne sont pas
encore prêtes à déposer plainte et ne
pas garder le prélèvement est bien ça
veut dire faire disparaître la preuve et
donc ensuite avoir du mal à faire
reconnaître justement son statut de
victime et surtout à faire reconnaître
la culpabilité de son agresseur
en d'autres termes comme vous le savez
ce combat contre les violences premier
pilier de la grande cause du quinquennat
mobilise l'ensemble du gouvernement
car les violences s'immisce dans toutes
les sphères de notre société et ignore
les frontières géographiques sociales ou
culturelles pour reprendre le titre de
votre rapport sur les femmes en ruralité
il ne doit y avoir en la matière aucune
zone blanche et nous y travaillerons
ensemble
vous avez également
signalé madame la présidente et nous en
avons déjà parlé ensemble parce que pour
moi c'est un sujet vraiment très
important et sur lequel je souhaite
m'investir avec la plus grande des
sincérités et j'allais dire aussi avec
le plus grand tombe engagements parce
que je sais que ce n'est pas un sujet
facile c'est celui de la pornographie de
l'industrie de la pornographie
vous avez vous avez consacré à ce sujet
des travaux que je sais très approfondie
dont j'attends les résultats avec
impatience je tiens d'ores et déjà
salué ce courage que vous avez eu à
prendre ce sujet à bras le corps et
c'est vraiment ce sujet constitue
vraiment un angle mort sur lequel nous
devons mettre la lumière vous pourrez
compter sur moi pour avancer sur ce
sujet si importante
mesdames et messieurs donc les sénateurs
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
ne se réduit pas est la lutte contre les
violences les questions de santé ont
également été au coeur de la gender du
gouvernement et de la majorité je pense
par exemple aux moyens inédits déployés
pour lutter contre la précarité
menstruel ainsi qu'à la stratégie
nationale de lutte contre l'endométriose
lancé par le président de la république
je pense aussi à l'allongement du délai
de recours à l'ivg est de douze à
quatorze semaines une liberté
fondamentale que vous avez évoquées dans
votre introduction madame la présidente
et qu'il convient de sécuriser
juridiquement
en effet nous l'avons observé avec
effroi récemment aux états unis le vent
du conservatisme souffle fort et érode
des acquis que nous pensions peut-être
naïvement définitivement inamovible
c'est pourquoi avec la première ministre
nous soutenons résolument la
constitutionnalisation de l'accès à
l'institut l interruption volontaire de
grossesse je me réjouis que le parlement
s'en soit 6 y signe que notre pays ne
cédera aucun millimètre face à la
régression qui s'opère au delà de nos
frontières
par ailleurs avec françois braun nous
travaillerons à lancer le bilan de
fertilité préventif pour tous des 29 ans
et nous instaurons aussi la possibilité
pour toutes les femmes de recourir à une
consultation pré ménopause pris en
charge intégralement par la sécurité
sociale
l'égalité professionnelle clé de
l'émancipation des femmes constitue
aussi une priorité
beaucoup a été accompli par le
gouvernement et la majorité
parlementaire lors du principe un
quinquennat on peut citer par exemple à
la création en 2018 de l'index de
l'égalité professionnelle
un outil de transparence pour résorber
les inégalités salariales et qui a déjà
fait les preuves de son efficacité
je pense aussi à la loi du 24 décembre
2021 visant à accélérer les gars
l'éthique économique et professionnelle
dont je veillerai très attentivement aux
effets concrets et je pense enfin à
l'allongement du congé paternité de 14 à
28 jours en vigueur depuis le 1er
juillet 2021
cet enjeu d' équilibre entre vie
personnelle et professionnelle doit
encore être renforcé avec mes collègues
ministre des solidarités et du travail
nous travaillerons sa renforcer les
dispositifs concernant la garde
d'enfants ainsi que les besoins
spécifiques des familles monoparentales
majoritairement dirigées par des femmes
en lien avec mes collègues du
gouvernement ainsi qu'avec vous je
souhaiterais également travaillé sur la
mixité des filières professionnelles
il faut élargir le cercle des femmes
susceptibles de pouvoir accéder à des
postes de responsabilités dans les
domaines scientifique et en particulier
et notamment dans celui du numérique
nous savons qu'il s'agit là de métiers
d'avenir et si les jeunes filles si les
femmes n'acceptent pas à ces métiers
d'avenir cela signifie defacto qu'elles
seront ils finalement exclu de de tous
ces postes à responsabilité dans
quelques années donc l'enjeu heures est
particulièrement fort il me semble que
nous devons pas rater ce train j'allais
dire vers l'émancipation économique pour
toutes les femmes
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
nous avons également parfaitement
conscience que les inégalités femmes
hommes sans racines dès l'enfance
etc pour moi vraiment un
chantier très important que j'ai d'ores
et déjà ouverts et je me si vous
souhaitez j'aimerais pouvoir vous
associer à ce travail
parce que
travailler sur l'éducation à l'égalité
filles garçons à la lutte contre les
stéréotypes à l'éducation à la vie
affective et sexuelle c'est un enjeu
sociétal je pense qu'il doit être pris
avec le plus grand des sérieux et qui
mérite aussi une concertation une
consultation et je souhaite pleinement
vous y associer aussi si vous en êtes
d'accord
en tout cas c'est un enjeu pour moi
important
lutter très tous contre tous les
stéréotypes c'est aussi une manière de
prévenir à terme les violences faites
aux femmes
l'enjeu de la parité
ne s'arrête pas aux frontières du
secteur privé la fonction publique doit
être exemplaire en la matière et
permettez moi dès lors deux salué
l'important travail d'évaluation que
vous avez menées sur les dix ans de la
loi sauvadet et comme j'ai pu le dire
hier soir je suis tout à fait
prenant preneuse pardon d'un d'un compte
rendu que vous accepteriez de me faire
sur ce rapport parce que je pense que
aussi je pourrais le porter auprès de
mon collègue de la fonction publique
donc évidemment nous je pense que nous
pouvons organiser une rencontre dans ce
sens là donc mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
le combat pour l'égalité est une longue
bataille une longue bataille qui doit
engager toutes nos sociétés
notre responsabilité en tant qu'acteur
politique est immense
je la mesure pleinement
pour réussir nous avons absolument
besoin les uns des lots les uns des
autres et nous devons travailler en
confiance et en synergie
nous avons une obligation de résultat
une obligation à la fois individuelle et
collective
je dirai aussi que les droits des femmes
ne sont ni ses câbles ni aliénable
fragile ils doivent néanmoins être
protégés constamment
ils le doivent céder le pas ni à la
fatalité synonyme de résignation ni aux
dogmes quel qu'il soit antagonismes de
la liberté c'est ensemble que nous
ferons avancer l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ils permettent un
mois d' employer de termes qui me sont
chers qui ne sont peut-être pas dans le
politiquement
correct mais régulièrement employés mais
que je trouve important c'est peut-être
dirons nous en sort au rite est avec
vous mesdames les sénatrices en
fraternité avec vous messieurs les
sénateurs et je pense que c'est vraiment
dans cet esprit là que vous que nous
pourrons avancer je sais
que je peux compter sur vous parce que
je connais déjà comme je voulais dire la
qualité de vos travaux et je me permets
de vous dire que vous pouvez compter sur
moi je vous remercie et je me tiens bien
sûr à votre disposition pour toutes les
questions que vous souhaiteriez nous
poser écoutez merci madame la ministre à
l' écoute de vos propos évidemment je ne
doute pas que nous allons pouvoir
travailler de concert ensemble comme ça
a été le cas avec votre prédécesseur
elisabeth moreno est l'équipe qui vous
entourent que je salue on retrouve des
visages familiers avec qui on avait une
des échanges fluides donc évidemment que
nous nous souhaitons comme vous que ce
travail soit seront menées de concert
pour les femmes et pour lutter contre
les violences faites aux femmes pour
avancer sur les vg pour avancer sur tous
les sujets de préoccupation parce que
s'il n'y a pas d'actualité par exemple
pour ligier il y en a toujours une
actualité sur les vg en réalité dans
tous les pays même en france puisque à
chaque fois qu'on ouvre le débat sur ce
sujet on sent de nombreuses crispation
donc évidemment nous devons rester
mobilisés je vous remercie vraiment pour
ses propos qui nous donne déjà quelques
pistes parce qu'ils ont été assez étayé
en termes de chiffres et parfois nous
avions du mal dans d'autres cours
d'autres années à obtenir des chiffres
donc merci pour tous les chiffres dont
vous nous avez communiqué et je vais
sans plus tarder pour ne pas monopoliser
la parole passer la parole à nos
collègues qui l'ont demandé et dans
l'ordre de demandes nous avons déjà
martine filleul ce que ce que je vous
propose c'est peut-être qu'on va prendre
mais toutes les quatre interventions qui
sont demandés en même temps parce qu'on
gagne du temps il ya donc les 5 donc
martine filleul lors d'art cause qui est
ambitieux avec nous laurence rossignol
laurence cohen et victoire jasmin
est
également micheline jack voilà je
voulais noté parce que sinon je vais me
tromper donc la parole est à martine
filleul et donc je ne doute pas qu'elle
a prié note du rendez-vous qu'on va
honorer très rapidement voilà à vous
chers collègues oui merci madame la
présidente merci madame la ministre pour
vos propos très constructif et très
positif et évidemment je me rendrai
disponible pour le rendez-vous poudrier
bien nous accorder avec ma collègue
dominique vais rien moi je voulais
évoquer rapidement trois sujets le
premier sur l'éducation comme mode de
prévention non seulement des violences
mais des inégalités d'une manière
générale entre les hommes et les femmes
vous y avez fait référence dans votre
propos et vous y faites souvent
référence dans les interviews que vous
pouvez accorder j'aimerais que vous nous
en disent y ait un tout petit peu plus
nos réserves en sang douteux pour la
suite un travail sur le sujet un
deuxième sujet concerné les inégalités
de salaires entre les hommes et les
femmes
ban où il y a beaucoup à dire sur
l'index pénicaud
moi je suis de celles qui pensent que
cet index a le mérite d'exister mais
qu'il doit évoluer et en particulier en
introduisant d'autres critères comme par
exemple on l'a évoqué souvent entre nous
la question du congé de paternité
donc j'aimerais connaître votre point de
vue à ce propos est également savoir si
vous pensez qu'il serait possible est
intéressant d'avoir aussi un index
pénicaud dans la fonction publique
territoriale d'un sujet qu'on a évoqué
hier avec monsieur guérini car les
inégalités de salaires dans la fonction
publique qui
normalement se devrait d'être exemplaire
ne l'est pas et donc il ya des progrès
vraiment à faire dans ce domaine
troisième sujet toujours aussi
brièvement
abordé la question de la parité en
politique une question qui m'est très
cher il est clair que nous avons fait
beaucoup de progrès dans ce domaine
grâce en particulier à un dispositif des
quotas il nous reste à franchir un pas
pour les communes de moins de 2000
habitants
où les femmes sont encore trop peu
présente et également dans les
intercommunalités est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est un sujet qu'on pourra aborder
rapidement ensemble ou ou à traduire de
manière législatives
merci beaucoup cher collègue laure
darcos qui est en visio avec nous merci
laurent merci merci président vous
m'entendez parfaitement
parfaitement mais merci même analyse
vous avez été en effet déjà complet
j'avais une première question
[Musique]
posée sur un texte et niko moi je
voulais même aller plus loin vous avez
des chiffres parce que on en parle
beaucoup mais c'est ce dont avait parlé
aussi mais est ce que vous avez eu des
chiffres sans citer forcément toutes les
entreprises
de pénalités qu'elle n'aurait plus à
payer pour ne pas avoir respecté la loi
et si je vais plus loin je suis d'accord
avec martine sur
le sel que ça puisse être pris en six
ans compte bien évidemment les nouveaux
conjure des nouveaux chais paternité
maternité
nous avions commencé à travailler sur
des retraites des femmes je ne sais pas
si gouvernement va remettre ce sujet
important sur la table dans les mois qui
viennent mais nous serons vigilants et
également parce qu'évidemment ce
parcours
salariale est également bien évidemment
corrélée aux problèmes
de la juste retraite de beaucoup de
femmes et moi je voulais également vous
poser une autre question donc c'est
passivement
quoi qu'on dressera un martyr
sur un texte et nico
également revenir sur nos rapports sur
la pornographie que beaucoup de mes
collègues ont suivi moi j'ai surtout été
extrêmement ébranlait surtout par l'axé
encore possible aux mineurs de vidéos
pornographiques ça fait des dizaines
d'années qu'on en parle c'était très
bien qu'aujourd'hui il suffit de cliquer
sur je 18 ans pour avoir accès à
énormément de vidéos on en a parlé avec
l'art comme qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
même celle d'un point de vue même aux
européens comment peut-on faire pour
essayer de régler ce problème
définitivement on a eu des témoignages
extrêmement poignant de psychologues et
des mots car nous disons que ces jeunes
sont définitivement totalement déformée
de
la vision de la sexualité et les
relations futures qui pourront après que
leur partenaire merci merci ans poursuit
donc madame la ministre les les
interventions donc laurence rossignol
est la présidente merci madame la
ministre pour votre propos est la façon
dont vous nous avez partagé avec nous
vos intentions et vos ambitions pour
votre trois ministères et je vous y
souhaite la plus grande réussite
quelques sujets alors je vais évoquer
des sujets je vais éviter de vous poser
des questions trop précises pour qui
supposerait que vous y répondit
aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup d'entre
elles sont de dimensions de pilotage
interministériel
je veux attirer votre attention dessus
pour les semaines et les mois à venir en
particulier pour la préparation du
budget du plfss pour l'une d'entre elles
première remarque sur la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes il ya eu
à partir de 2004 cinq plans de lutte
interministérielle à contre les
violences faites aux femmes
donc de 2004 à 2010 9 qui ont quand même
manifester à la fois la continuité du
travail l'approfondissement à chaque
fois chaque sans doute donné lieu à une
évaluation du précédent et indiqué
le cap de traiter de sujets nouveaux qui
avait été jusqu'à présent pas à
appréhender moi je regrette que en 2019
le grenelle est l occasion de mettre fin
à cette continuité et je voudrais vous
demander si vous avez l'intention de
reprendre le fil qui montre quand même
une volonté de l'état et une volonté
interministériel et qui al'avantage
d'avoir en plus une visibilité
intéressante ça c'était rien qu'un
deuxième remarque concerne l'action de
la justice
je pense que je crois que l'on peut
observer une mobilisation des parquets
et de la justice pénale qui est
qualitativement différente de ce qu'on a
connu par le passé sur la question des
violences faites aux femmes en revanche
je crois qu'on a toujours un problème
dans la justice civile une partie des
violences faites aux femmes se noue
d'abord dans le cabinet du jaf
[Musique]
il y avait deux magistrales madame
ministre une vo collaboratrice des deux
magistrates à cette table mes collègues
de délégation des femmes connaissent mon
mon obsession sur le sujet de la justice
civile j'entends que vous parlez de
travailler sur la mise en place d'une
justice spécialisée pour ma part je
plaide pour une justice familiale
et civiles et pénales dans une justice
et spécialisés et c'est pas simplement
une partie du cabinet d'une partie du
parquet qui doit se spécialiser ou une
partie de la 2d tribunaux de jce pénal
c'est l'action de l'interaction et de
entre pénales et civiles les espagnols
ne sont pas deux jusque là puisque la
justice se spécialiser en espagne n'a
pas totalement fusionnée justice
familiale et justice pénale et j'ajoute
aussi que la question du juge pour
enfant quand même dans cette affaire là
parce qu'une le juge que la justice pour
enfants et parfois aussi un moyen de
pression sur les maires et voilà il dans
les violences psychologiques une grande
partie se joue dans la justice civile et
pas simplement au pénal jeudi vous de
vous faire cette remarque là qu'est ce
que vous pensez
ensuite je lance de protection de
permettre au parquet de prononcé des
ordonnances de protection puisque en ce
moment actuellement c'est le jaf qui
dénoue dans des cas cette faculté la
voilà je met ma religion pas totalement
fait dont je fus rieuse de savoir quelle
est la vôtre sur le sujet enfin 2 3 tout
petits sujets sains sur le cmg famille
monoparentale homoparentale promesse du
président de la république
allongement du cmg du comté en mode de
garde excusez moi de mon expression le
courrier en mode de garde versée par les
caisses d'allocations familiales et
jusqu'à 6 ans il ya demande pour que ça
verser jusqu'à 12 ans pour les familles
monoparentales c'est un engagement du
président de la république est ce que
votre collègue ministre des solidarités
entend l'inclure dans le plfss
nous nous avons un sujet qui en ce
moment - lobbies mais parce qu'à un
moment que je voyais venir faut que je
prouve que j'avais identifié c'est sur
lequel nous n'avançons pas assez la part
des femmes dans les écoles d'ingénieurs
qui est un fait pour dire les choses
simplement ça fait 40 ans qu'on a
identifié le problème quarante ans qu'on
fait des preuves et des campagnes la
première c'était celle d'yvette roudy
limité n'ont pas de sexe voilà 40 ans et
ça ne bouge pas et les femmes sont dans
les squats d'ingénieurs sont concentrées
sur biologie et chimie pour tout le
reste on ne sont des pans départ on ne
passe pas le plafond des 15 à 17%
je ne crois plus à la pédagogie je ne
crois plus à la bonne volonté des
directeurs je ne crois plus à tout ça le
faut tirer le bilan de notre échec
collectif et commun enfin collectif
n'est pas politique c'est un échec de
société et je crois qu'on faut qu'on
réfléchisse à des mesures plus
coercitives nous avons fait un peu le
tour des mesures incitatives en la
matière l'élection des quotas et enfin
manami j'ai fait passer un message
identique à votre collègue ministre and
education franchement si dans deux ans
tous les deux vous pouvez nous dire que
les cours d'éducation à la vie affective
et sexuelle sont tenues dans corps dans
tous les établissements que après le
rapport du haut conseil à l'égalité de
2016 j'aimerais bonne le rapport de
l'igas que j'ai toujours pas lui
d'ailleurs c'est le seul rapport secret
défense que je connaissais ni de casser
le rapport sur les comptes éducation
affective et sexuelle ça rapport au
commun igas inspection générale d'une
question nationale
mais je sais qu'au rapport confirme les
rapports précédents malheureusement
voilà un bel un bel objectif pour vos
deux ministères c'est que la prochaine
fois ce soit 95 % des élèves y ait eu
accès aux cours élevés son étude échange
avec télé sexuelle parce que c'est là où
se joue une partie d'éducation au
consentement de la lutte contre les
violences voilà merci
merci beaucoup
chers collègues c'est vrai que si notre
religion n'est pas tout à fait fait sur
certains sujets sur le sujet de
l'éducation là notre religion et est
tout à fait claire et précise au sein de
la délégation par rapport à cette ces
mesures sur la la loi qui oblige et rien
n'est appliquée puisque on a pu se
rendre dans un collège dans le
département de notre collègue laurence
cohen qui je vais passer la parole et
qui a bien démontré les défaillances du
système merci donc c'est dommage
d'ailleurs ne pas avoir de religion sur
tous les sujets parce qu'on est quand
même dans une chapelle
à vous chers collègues
oui merci madame la présidente merci
madame la ministre pour vos propos
introductif qui effectivement
sont nature à nous réjouir puisque vous
avez plusieurs fois manifesté le désir
en fait qui est le nôtre il à dire
d'avoir un travail
collaboratif et ça c'est appréciable à
partir du moment où on mène les mêmes
les mêmes lutter conte et en vise le
même le même but donc voilà je vous en
remercie déjà beaucoup de choses ont été
dites je voudrais insister sur plusieurs
points un premier point c'est par
rapport aux violences
faites aux femmes vous nous avez donné
un certain nombre d'éléments mes
collègues ont posé des questions je
voudrais avoir peut-être un peu plus de
précisions sur votre positionnement
concernant les les tribunaux spécialisés
d'après ce que j'ai parce que bon le ya
de nombreuses associations féministes
qui serait favorable à ces tribunaux sur
le modèle de ce qui se passe en espagne
mais j'ai cru comprendre mais vous allez
me dire que vous n'êtes plus favorable
on va dire à une justice
spécialisée et donc je voulais je
voulais un peu avoir votre
votre éclairage là dessus c'est à dire
que moi il me semble
depuis la responsabilité qui est la
mienne que l'important c'est que
finalement il y ait des moyens qu'ils
soient donnés à la justice parce que
quand même elle en manque singulièrement
mais quand je parle de moyens c'est
évidemment des moyens humains ce sont
des moyens en terme de formation de
formation initiale mais aussi de
formation continue et puis ce qui me
semble aussi important c'est des moyens
permettant de coordonner aussi des
actions afin que ça travaille dans le
même sens quand il s'agit de deux
d'endiguer les violences faites aux
femmes donc voilà je voudrais avoir un
peu plus de précision là dessus j'ai
entendu aussi que vous comptiez et c'est
une bonne chose
continuer à développer les filières
d'urgence dans le traitement judiciaire
bon j'ai l'impression qu'il ya donc un
certain nombre déjà deux tribunaux qui
ont cessé filière d'urgence mais
j'aimerais un petit peu en avoir un peu
plus d'éléments moi j'ai noté à peu près
120 tribunaux sur 160 enfin voila mais
c'est plutôt bon voilà en quoi ça
consiste
quels sont les moyens renforcés ça c'est
donc la première question que je voulais
vous poser concernant également les
violences nous avons beaucoup travaillé
au niveau de la délégation aux droits
des femmes sur
la les personnes qui sont
prostituées que l'on prostituent il y a
eu donc une loi la loi de 2016 nous
avons été ici parmi celles et ceux qui
se sont battus pour que cette loi soit
votée ça n'a pas été sans mal et
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
il n'ya pas une véritable volonté en
tout cas affiché de faire en sorte que
cette loi puisse disposer de moyens
permettant effectivement une sortie de
de la prostitution pour celles et ceux
qui en manifeste
la volonté donc j'aimerais savoir qu'est
ce que vous comptez faire pour appuyer
cette loi qui me semble essentiel parce
que la prostitution c'est une une
violence terrible qui est faite aux
femmes la deuxième deuxième focus je
vais continuer sur l'égalité salariale
on est quand même en 2022 il ya toujours
pas d'égalité salariale réelle
bon il ya un indice
qui a été pénicaud et cetera mais vous
savez pertinemment que les remis en
cause par bon nombre de syndicats si ce
n'est pas si ce n'est par tous les
syndicats parce qu'en réalité à
l'application n'est pas des plus
fortes on va le dire comme ça et qu à
chaque fois qu en tout cas dans
l'hémicycle avec mon groupe nous avons
proposé de forcer un peu sur les
pénalités aux entreprises s'étaient
jamais le moment et quand on voit là
j'ai pas pris les chiffres avec moi mais
il ya très peu d'entreprises qui sont
poursuivis parce qu'elles n'ont pas
appliqué la loi et on redonne toujours
du temps au temps pour qu'elle se mette
en conformité - il me semble qu'à un
moment donné quand la loi existe elle
doit être appliquée et qui ne doit pas y
avoir de dérogation induites am aeternam
sur un principe qui me semble qui me
semble fondamental donc j'aimerais
savoir est-ce que vous avez la tension
pardonnez moi l'expression peut-être un
peu triviale mais de passer à une
vitesse supérieure permettant qui est
une vraie égalité salariale et donc un
cheminement plus important vers
l'égalité professionnelle ça ça me
semble important est la toute dernière
question je voudrais vous poser elle ne
vous a pas été posée c'est au moment où
on nous avons travaillé sur la loi de
bioéthique
donc nous avons voté en faveur de
l'accès de la pma pour tout et c'est
vraiment
quelque chose très important mais en
même temps on avait pressenti que
il pourrait y avoir des difficultés
s'avère que les retours que nous avons
cédé délai qui reste d'attentes qui
reste très longue faut notamment de
centres suffisant aussi de gamme est
donc est-ce que vous avez des éléments
là dessus à nous fournir pour un peu
faire en sorte que les délais soient
soit moins long et de manière peut-être
qui est moins - généraliste mais qui est
importante d'autant que vous êtes
magistrate on a évoqué un cas c'est le
problème de l'établissement de la
filiation
pour les couples ayant débuté un
parcours de pma à l'étranger avant la
loi mais dont l'enfant est né après la
loi visiblement dans ce cas de figure la
deuxième mère doit recourir à l'adoption
comme avant la loi c'est à dire qu'elle
est en quelque sorte
elles ne bénéficient pas finalement du
dispositif qui a été qui a été voté
votre collègue ministre de la justice a
été saisie mais le retour que nous en
avons ce qu' il ne souhaite pas modifier
les choses or là on voit bien que ça
crée une discrimination entre les
couples de femmes selon en fait la date
de conception et donc est ce que vous
avez
enfin vous avez été saisi de cette
question est est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
un travail pour éviter que des couples
se trouvent hors
la loi entend quelque sorte mais ne
disposition ne disposant pas plutôt de
ce dispositif qui est plutôt positif et
voilà et puis enfin un tout petit
dernier mot c'est sur le budget est-ce
que sans nous parler du fait que c'est
un budget transversale que il englobe
tout ce qui est du domaine du
co-développement et c est ce qu il va
rester toujours le plus petit budget de
l'état ou es ce que vous avez de
l'espoir qu'ils puissent être renforcé
en tout cas nous conjuguons nos efforts
aux vôtres pour qu'il en soit ainsi je
vous remercie merci chère laurence donc
la parole trois dernières demandes de
prise de parole on va passer on va
voyager puisque ces trois sénatrice des
territoires ultramarins donc d'abord
victoire jasmin micheline jack et lana
tetuanui et ensuite madame la ministre
je vous laisserai la parole avec
beaucoup beaucoup de questions
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
merci madame la ministre y merci pour
vos propos introductif qu'ils y ont été
vraiment
le sens que nous souhaitons madame la
ministre y attirer votre attention sur
la situation des femmes les différents
territoires d'outre-mer qui sont
contraintes pour les formations
promotionnelle devenir systématiquement
pour beaucoup de formation par exemple
les chefs d'établissement en milieu
scolaire les cadres de santé et beaucoup
d'autres métiers en tout cas qui sont
confrontés au fait qu'il faille revenir
dans l'hexagone pour ces formations
alors que maintenant on se rend bien
compte qu'il y a des difficultés par
rapport à la loi la loi climat par
rapport au gaz à effet de serre par
rapport au coût des billets d'avion mais
aussi aux difficultés que rencontrent
ces familles qui sont obligés d'être
séparés parce que les femmes la plupart
du temps s'occupe des enfants ils sont
contrés de venir ici un hexagone avec
des enfants d'avoir un double foyer pour
un an ses formations alors je voudrais
attirer votre attention pour permettre
que pour les chefs d'établissement pour
que les femmes aient la possibilité
d'être promu parce qu'elles ont les
compétences la plupart du temps il est
pré requis nécessaires
toutefois c'est un point important donc
il y est d'une part des regroupements
ponctuel mais que les formations
puissent se faire par visioconférence ou
alors faire se déplacer le formateur
pour des regroupements de professionnels
en termes de maîtrise des dépenses je
crois que ce serait beaucoup plus
pertinent compte tenu des obligations
que nous avons deux parties d'autres et
surtout pour les coûts et sur la
priorité familiale la deuxième chose
madame la ministre votre prédécesseur
est venu juste avant la fed de la
dernière mandature en outre-mer et
particulièrement en guadeloupe et là on
compterait plusieurs associations qui
ont mis beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir en
cette visite et qui ont apprécié de
proposer un certain nombre de
dispositions de dispositifs et surtout
pour les associations votre prédécesseur
a rencontré notamment la présidente de
l'association amalgame humaniste qui
a à sa charge une ligne d'écouté arc en
ciel qui favorise un petit peu les
appels des personnes victimes
d'homophobie donc il y à de gros
problèmes sur nos territoires il
particulièrement en guadeloupe sur ces
sujets là donc j'aurais vraiment
souhaité qu'il y ait un accent
particulier sur cette problématique de
l'homophobie parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes et certaines des personnes qui
accompagnent et madame la ministre à
l'époque ont été prises ont été entendus
ils sont présentes aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs entendu la souffrance des
personnes concernées et là je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup à faire parce que nous
avons des personnes qui malheureusement
passer à l'acte et ans ne se suicider et
ce serait vraiment dommage alors que
quand même sept jeunes de dispositif
permettrait de les aider davantage les
associations ont aussi besoin d'un
accompagnement particulier mais là vous
aurez l'occasion vous avez déjà dans
tout cas certain nombre d'éléments et je
ne vais pas m'étaler là-dessus
concernant l'orientation des filles et
leur affectation alors et des efforts
sont à faire
notamment au niveau de l'éducation
nationale pour une meilleure formation
des personnels du service académique
d'orientation et de l'orientation et
d'affectation et d'information parce que
très souvent les fiches métiers ne sont
pas mises à jour et il y a un vrai sujet
dont j'aurais souhaité vraiment est
lancé l'ancien cadre de santé qu part
qu'il y ait un véritable travail pour la
mise à jour des connaissances
d'autre part il ya le problème de
dissiper harcèlement alors nous avons
décollé ici au sénat qui ont fait un
travail remarquable sur le cyber
harcèlement il y a eu une proposition de
loi mais il faudrait quand même que nous
puissions porter une attention toute
particulière à cette problématique dans
les établissements scolaires elie dans
les dans les collèges en particulier
emma en matière de prévention il ya
encore beaucoup à faire voilà je mérite
mais là je vous remercie une fois de
plus merci à vous tous il y avoue tout
meersman la présidente merci chers
collègues micheline jack merci madame le
président alain la ministre chers
collègues je souhaiterais seulement
ajouter une observation pour dire ma
conviction de la nécessité à trouver un
dispositif de protection y compris
matériel des enfants orphelins
à la suite de violences conjugales c'est
un sujet sur lequel j'espère que le
gouvernement s'investit rats et pourra
conduire une réflexion en cours je vous
remercie
écoute merci et micheline pour la
concision et donc la dernière
intervenante ont fini par la polynésie
donc lana tetuanui
merci madame la noria marie pierre mony
qui interviendra peut-être après en
visio
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre collègues y aura cet après midi
je rejoins tout à fait tout ce qui a été
dit tout ce qui a été dit depuis le
début et malheureusement tous ces maux
tous ces problèmes sociétaux existe
aussi mais à vingt mille kilomètres
d'ici et ce qui est plus complexe que
dans nos collectivités et je parle ou la
polynésie où les compétences sociales
et éducation et tout le reste ce sont
une compétence de la collectivité
polynésie et que l'état à travers la
justice ne peut qu'être venir ça tous
les sujets se rejoint
c'est vrai que le président de la
république avait avait mis en priorité
grande cause du précédent quinquennat
des violences
intra familiaux et je tenais ma dans le
ministre avait remercié vision macro
d'avoir pu donner une subvention
à l'association qui défend les droits
des femmes en polynésie pour les aider à
construire un nouveau bâtiment justement
pour avoir plus de places
dédiées pour toutes ces femmes qui
subissent les violences
aussi bien dans leur foyer moi j'aurais
juste deux questions le plus important
pour moi pour toi pourquoi ne pas mettre
en place comme ça a été fait pour le
foncier un problème récurrent est
récurrent en polynésie française et un
tribunal foncier c'est le président
actuel il doit friche à l'époque où il
était député qui avait demandé
ça ici à paris et nous avons obtenu un
tribunal foncier en polynésie française
parce que ce qui est complexe dans notre
territoire c'est aussi bien
les problèmes sur l'île de tahiti mais
il y à aussi l'éloignement des autres
des autres îles dont les autres
archipels c'est important tellement
c'est notre territoire est vaste et on
retrouve les mêmes problèmes même dont
les peut tout petit in pourquoi pas
mettre en place un tribunal mais dédié
à toute cette cause là parce que ce qui
me chagrine c'est tous les mois d'août
ou de septembre c'est la saision c'est
la session des assises au tribunal de
papeete voilà à tous bras et tout le
monde est là aussi bien assises ont
trait de les autres affaires moi
j'aimerais bien en tant que
parlementaire qu'il y ait un tribune
dédiée à ces
problèmes
lié aux violences faites aux femmes aux
enfants
en oublions pas bien sûr qui a l'aspect
culturel aussi qui prime beaucoup aussi
dans les collectivités ouais parce que
voilà et la religion parce que depuis la
nuit des temps la place des femmes c'est
un peu comme au centre
en deuxième place dans la société par
contre au niveau politique la parité a
été obligé par une loi votée ici en
france fait ce qu'on vous dit de faire
mais il ne fait pas ce que l'on fait la
parité est déjà applicable aussi bien
dans les assemblées et dans les communes
de polynésie sauf celles de moins de
1000 habitants on a de l'avancé sur ce
sujet là et le dernier sujet promotion
des femmes dans le corps préfectoral
de toute ma vie j'ai vu une seule près
fait venir l'officier polynésie
française sinon depuis on voit que des
ombres passé c'est pas que je suis
anti haut-commissaire aux antilles
préfet ça serait bien de pousser un peu
la promotion des femmes dans le corps
préfectoral
merci madame la ministre et une dernière
intervention par visio marie pierre
monnier qui étaient avec nous tout à
l'heure en séance et qui est pas loin de
prendre son train très court si tu peux
te le faire cher m'arrêterai à courtrai
commercy bonjour madame un ministre
toutes mes félicitations de vive-voix
redis je vous ai déjà écrit et merci
pour votre accueil et hier deux choses
d'abord je voulais dit nous avons fait
la présidente la cité nous avons fait un
rapport sur sam et ruralité vous savez
qu'en réalité parmi tous les films d'ici
deux ans en france 50% du en zone rurale
alors que seulement un tiers des
familles dit évident c'est dire si le
sujet vraiment crucial et s'il ya
beaucoup à faire là dessus nous avons
fait 60 et d'ir comble alors je pense
que tu peux couper la vidéo parce que
c'est c'est extrêmement voilà et donc il
y en a une qui me tient à coeur parce
que ce sont souvent les élus des petites
communes qui sont sollicités les élus en
général mais dans les petites communes
c'est les élus qui vont au front pour
ces sujets là et je pense que ce serait
intéressant parce que des associations
nationales me l'ont dit de nommer
d'instaurer un référent qualité au sein
des communes des intercommunalités qui
pourrait justement gérer ces problèmes
là de droits des femmes et de violences
faites aux femmes j'avais essayé de
porter des amendements qui ne sont pas
passés faire un amendement qui n'est pas
passée mais en discutant avec votre
prédécesseur il n'apparaissait que ce
serait peut-être plutôt d'ordre
réglementaire et donc le décret
suffirait la deuxième chose sur laquelle
je souhaite vous alerter c'est sur le
fait que dans les plats dans les aides
aux associations que vous faites ce sont
souvent des appels à projets qu'il est
très difficile pour les petites
associations implantées ruralité qui
font pourtant un travail tout à fait
remarquable et indispensable de se
positionner sur des appels à
manifestation parce qu'elles n'ont pas
la taille pour elles n'ont pas l'aide
pour porter ces dossiers là pour les
construire souvent voilà je serai pas
plus longue et je vous remercie par
avance pour vos réponses mais écoutez
madame la ministre vous avez deux heures
pour répondre en réalité toutes ces
questions et toutes ses interventions
des collègues qui a été extrêmement
variés qui touchait beaucoup dessus
montre tout l'intérêt que nous portons à
ces sujets de droits des femmes
d'égalité salariale de lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales je vais vous
laisser vous préparer à répondre aux
nombreuses questions et interventions et
merci à toutes les collègues parce que
c'est vrai que les sujets étaient
extrêmement variés et pointu donc merci
pour vos questions
madame la mise c'est à vous avec le
micro comme ça à distance faut appuyer
juste devant sous le papier voilà
parfait et bien je vous remercie
mesdames les sénatrices pour toutes ces
questions
qui montrent vraiment votre implication
dans ce sujet et puis aussi votre
excellente connaissance de de tous les
domaines
ne m'en voulez pas si je ne peux pas
répondre de manière exhaustive à toutes
vos questions je vais le faire le mieux
possible et puis il ya des sujets comme
laurence aussi a pu l'indiquer sur eux
sur lesquels il n'est pas possible
d'apporter forcément une réponse
aujourd'hui mais dont je pourrais
effectivement mentionné l'intérêt est
aussi revenir ensuite vers vous en
disant que tient là dessus on peut
avancer ou voilà qu'elle quelles sont
les pistes de réflexion
alors je vais commencer je vais prendre
par ordre chronologique
donc c'était les questions de madame la
sénatrice martine filleul donc
concernant donc vous aviez donc rappeler
votre rapport sur l'égalité la fonction
publique donc le mot cabinet m'indique
que dès demain d'ailleurs vous re pour
vous recevrez un mail avec des
propositions note noura rendez vous
voilà
s'agissant de l'éducation comme comme
mode de prévention donc vous suit vous
souhaitiez je vous en dit un peu plus
c'est un peu délicat de vous en dire
plus que c'est un à la fois je ma
feuille de route n'est pas encore
complètement acté et puis c'est un
chantier qui se veut justement ouvert
donc ouvert à la fois avec le ministère
de l'éducation nationale mais aussi
justement avec les différents
partenaires il est aussi les
parlementaires à venir dont vous faites
partie donc nous allons voir ce sur quoi
nous allons aboutir ce qui est sûr
c'est que
en tout cas moi y'a des granges à dire
des grands principes que j'aimerais
pouvoir commander revoir appliquez enfin
on peut dire une ossature peut-être
pourrait être présente c'est que je
pense qu'il faut penser à communiquer à
sensibiliser plus tôt à différents âges
qu'il faut commencer à cîteaux alors
comme je le dis moi je n'ai pas de
certitudes et puis je n'aime pas les
discours péremptoire donc c'est
difficile de dire à quel âge précisément
d'où l'intérêt de concerter de consulter
et de s'entourer aussi d'avis pourquoi
pas de science de spécialistes de
sciences de l'éducation bon voilà mais à
un jeune âge qu'on pourrait dire 608
enfin bon voilà un âge assez jeune
j'allais dire une transmission du bea
bas pour éduquer à l'égalité filles
garçons est la lutte aussi quand les
stéréotypes je vais pas vous détailler
vous êtes tout des spécialistes des
droits des femmes donc je vais pas vous
détailler vous expliquer l'intérêt de
lutter contre les stéréotypes dès le
plus jeune âge et puis je pense
qu'ensuite il faut prévoir une autre un
autre moment justement de
sensibilisation au collège où j'allais
dire on aborde les autres questions et
on peut qui pourrait d'ailleurs être se
rapprocher davantage d'une prévention
des violences sexuelles et sexistes
voilà on peut aussi par exemple parler
du consentement enfin bon un certain
nombre de questions de cet ordre
j'en profite tout parce que je réponds
que c'est un petit peu en même temps
à laurence rossignol / sur le rapport en
question
sur le rapport qui avait été fait par
l'inspection générale sur l'éducation à
la vie sexuelle et affective donc je
vais me rapprocher
du ministre de l'éducation nationale je
pense pas a priori je pense qu'il
devrait pouvoir être transmis
je pense qu'il faut intégrer bien sûr
cet enseignement et mais néanmoins c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'il faut être
beaucoup dans la concertation il faut
avoir conscience
aussi que
c'est un sujet qui provoque aussi
beaucoup de
beaucoup de résistance et que si on veut
réussir parce que ce qui compte c'est
aussi de réussir c'est pas d'imposer
forcément quelque chose qui après pour
fera l'objet d'un rejet et donc si on
veut réussir il faut vraiment je pensais
d'en emmener avec nous sur l'élaboration
de ce 2 de ce programme faut pas dire
programme s'était pas exactement ça m'a
fait se plante ce programme ayant en
tête comme vous savez certainement que
vous pouvez avoir un certain nombre de
familles qui peuvent être
parfois réticentes à ce que cet
enseignement soit fait enfin je veux
dire de tous les déplacements que je
fais on m'a dit que des parents par
exemple qui enlèvent leurs enfants de
l'école lorsqu'ils savent qu'il y aura
un enseignement de cet ordre qui va être
dispensé voilà donc en fait voilà je
pense que d'où l'intérêt de consulter
largement pour le plus possible être
dans dans un objet qui soit le plus
consensuel possible parce qu'il s'agit
bien là me semble-t-il d'un sujet
sociétal
et qui concerne aussi la société demain
et aussi la formation d avenir de demain
que nous voulons plus fraternelle plus
respectueux aussi
des de l'égalité entre les filles et les
hommes entre les entre les femmes et les
hommes et puis aussi à un terreau plus
propice à l'émancipation des filles
enfin et c'est au choix des carrières
enfin tout ce que tout ce qu'on peut
tout ce qu'on sait de l'intérêt
justement à dispenser at elle une telle
sensibilisation qui couvrent différents
domaines donc voilà je ne sais pas quel
calendrier je peux vous proposer ce que
je sais c'est que nous nous nous avons
commencé à travailler déjà entre les
deux cabinets
et que nous je pense qu'avec le mini de
l'éducation nous pourrons peut-être
proposer justement un calendrier
peut-être mois de septembre pour avancer
sur ce pour sur ce sujet qui est
fondamental est que nous ne vont pas
gâcher en allant trop vite
vous avez aussi pointé d'une égalité des
salaires et vous avez le fait référence
à la ddt ex pénicaud considérant qu'il
devait évoluer je pense qu'il est
peut-être encore un peu tout pour
apporter une réponse précise sur ce
point mais qu'en revanche peut-être
qu'un important travail d'évaluation de
la nex devra être mené avant peut-être
d'envisager
une évolution de l'outil
je tiens aussi à vous indiquer que
depuis mon arrivée au ministère
j'ai pris contact et je rencontre afin
aussi de coûts construire avec eux un
certain nombre de réseaux professionnels
notamment des réseaux féminins mais pas
que et puis aussi
de consulter les entreprises les grandes
les grandes entreprises sur l'index pour
comprendre l'usagé qu'ils en font et
quelles seraient les axes d'amélioration
éventuelle donc sur ce point là encore
je pense qu'il faut continuer ce travail
de co construction j'attire aussi votre
attention ça peut aussi peut-être
susciter votre intérêt sur
l'important travail d'évaluation qu'il
faut aussi effectuer
vous avez aussi
évoqué donc la parité en politique les
communes non j'ai juste on m'avait
indiqué quelques chiffres quand même sur
l'index publico sur l'application donc
il ya eu cinq cent quatre mises en
demeure je réponds aussi à laure darcos
en même temps
504 mise en demeure trente deux
pénalités financières
trente deux mille quatre cent soixante
opération de contrôle voilà c'est les
chiffres donc
voilà c'est ça hein voilà
alors j'ai marqué pour excuser moi je
sais que comme vous êtes plusieurs
le coup je vois là
j'avais groupe et donc cela sur la
parité en politique dans les communes de
moins de 1000 habitants
vous comprendrez je peux pas vous
répondre effectivement comme ça devant
je dire d'emblée mais effectivement
c'est un point qui peut être peut être
examinés et discutés voilà voilà et
peut-être quand même indiqué
que sera lancée donc en septembre
prochain à baromètre de l'égalité
professionnelle sur le modèle de l'index
pénicaud dans la fonction publique voilà
et donc qui permettra de lutter
efficacement pour réduire les écarts de
rémunération voilà qui sont
inadmissibles dans la fonction publique
on peut aussi parler de la mise en place
du programme talentueuse qui est un
programme de coaching pour les femmes
dirigeantes de la fonction publique
c'est un programme inédit
d'accompagnement et de formation
destinés à 50 femmes de la haute
fonction publique et qui s'inscrit aussi
dans la volonté du gouvernement de
renforcer justement les forces vives
féminine pour former la génération de
dirigeants de demain de la fonction
publique on aura une première promotion
en novembre 2000 21
donc ah oui c'est ça donc je pense à peu
près avoir faire le tour de vos
questions donc s'agissant des questeurs
de madame la sénatrice laure darcos donc
du coup excusez moi mais je vous ai j'ai
un petit peu répondu à votre question
sur l'index pénicaud vous avez aussi
attiré mon attention
sur les retraites des femmes
bien sûr nous savons qu'une grande
différents choix que c'est de l'ordre de
40% que les retraites des femmes sont à
peu près en moyenne
40% inférieure à celle des hommes
je pense qu'il ya en fait comme pour sûr
comme sur de nombreux sujets en fait on
voit qu'il faut
actionner différents leviers alors bien
sûr qu'il y aura effectivement 8 gilles
ans particulière à avoir si le sujet des
retraites revient dans le débat
politique évidemment et je serai
vigilante sur le point sur ce point mais
je pense aussi qu'il ne faut pas oublier
et pour avoir été haute fonctionnaire à
l'égalité femmes hommes du ministère de
la justice et avoir travaillé justement
sur des cohortes
sur les différences salariales on voit
bien aussi que parfois ce qui se joue
c'est les intérêts les temps partiel qui
sont pris quand même encore trop souvent
que par les femmes plus les
interruptions de carrière et ce qui fait
que ben ensuite malheureusement tout
cela se répercute sur le sur les
retraites et je pense que c'est pourquoi
nous avons aussi à travailler justement
quand les femmes sont en activité pour
peut-être leur éviter de prendre à temps
partiel c'est à dire ça concerne aussi
tout ce qu'on peut faire pour améliorer
aussi d' équilibre entre vie
professionnelle et personnelle c'est
pour ça qu'on voit bien que ce sujet il
fait appel à de nombreuses actions qui
doivent tout se conjuguer pour aller
finalement dans le même sens celui d'une
plus grande égalité entre les femmes et
des hommes vous avez abordé le sujet de
la pornographie
voilà donc j'ai pu le dire combien je
trouvais courageux le fait que vous en
soyez emparé au sénat donc là je ne vais
pas vous répondre puis ce que j'attends
justement votre rapport les conclusions
les pistes que vous pourrez dégagé et
est ce que je vous suggère c'est que
nous discutions que nos échangions
ensemble bien sûr à l'issue de ce
rapport parce que je suis sûr
connaissant vos qualités des uns et des
autres que vous aurez des pistes
intéressantes qu'il nous faudra creuser
de mon côté mais aussi certainement
j'imagine que j'aurai des collègues à
interpeller aussi sur ce sujet pour
pouvoir avancer donc
je pense que nous nous pourrons à ce
moment là et changer et je vous donne
d'ores et déjà rendez vous pour la
restitution de ce rapport
donc je s'agissant donc des questions de
laurence rossignol
donc vous avez évoqué les violences
faites aux femmes les cinq plans
successifs l'idée de reprendre le fil
la volonté interministériel j'allais
dire elle existe dans le temps elles
existent dans le grenelle des violences
conjugales puisque c'est bien un travail
interministériel puisque tous les mini
fans combien je pense au moins une
douzaine de ministères étant appliqué
sur ce sujet néanmoins j'entends aussi
le sens de la question dans la mesure où
on a focalisé particulièrement sur les
violences conjugales
cela ne couvre pas tout le champ des
violences faites aux femmes en
particulier des violences sexuelles qui
sont commises hors de la sphère
familiale et cela fait partie j'allais
dire des
des pistes sur lesquelles je souhaite
travailler pour y introduire aussi
davantage à terme ici réalité
malheureusement là je ne peux pas vous
en dire plus aujourd'hui mais je pense
que très vite
courant septembre
voilà j'aurai les éléments pour répondre
plus précisément sur ce côté
interministériel
vous avez oui c'est ça vous avez donc
vous êtes revenue sur cette notion de
justice spécialisée de la justice pénale
de la justice civile
je pense alors c'est pas du tout pour
défendre le monde judiciaire même si
j'en suis issue mais je pense qu'il ya
quand même une appropriation quand même
des mesures au civil et je vous ai
mentionné tout à l'heure le taux
d'acceptation des ordonnances de
protection qui est de plus de 71% on
voit bien qu'il ya une sensibilisation
mais qui j'insiste aussi sur le fait
qu'ils n'aient pas que le fait des
magistrats parce que en fait pour aussi
que ces ordonnances sont prononcés
échoue aussi que les requêtes soient
bien formés bien finaliser avec aussi
les bons éléments donc c'est vraiment
l'ensemble des acteurs encore une fois
qu'ils doivent être bien formé
pour qu'on puisse aboutir justement des
résultats intéressants
néanmois j'entends tout à fait c'est je
pense que c'est vraiment là dessus aussi
qu'il faut travailler sur cette
interaction entre le civil et pénal le
gie e
je pense que c'est ça me permet de dire
que c'est jeu ça me permet aussi de
répondre à vous madame la sénatrice coin
vous avez aussi évoquer ce sujet de la
justice spécialisée bon le terme employé
par le président de la république c'est
pour juridictionnelle spécialisés c'est
ce qui figure dans le programme
présidentiel je pense que c'est un
l'objet n'est pas encore défini voilà on
ne fait pas je vais dire une réforme
comme ça d'un claquement de doigts voilà
je pense que ça nécessite justement là
aussi un travail préparatoire
un travail de fond on ne sait on sait
bien aussi que c'est un travail complexe
qui devra être mené nous aurons aussi
besoin de vous sur ce sujet pour pour
avancer dans ce travail
on ne pourra pas avoir exactement la
même chose à créteil ou à tulle voilà et
donc il faut penser aussi à système qui
puisse s'adapter justement selon la
taille des juridictions madame la
sénatrice vous avez aussi parlé de deux
juridictions spécialisées en polynésie
donc voilà je pense qu'il faudra que
nous ayons bien tout cela en tête et que
le plus possible nous arrivions
à faire à avoir des solutions qui soient
le plus adapté plus adaptable possible
selon la taille des jeux édition des
villes et puis la richesse ou non des
tissus du tissu local la richesse du
tissu associatif
enfin bon voilà donc en fait il ya plein
de paramètres à prendre en compte c'est
très complexe très complexe et et c'est
là aussi c'est un peu comme si alors là
j'avoue que moi joutes des chantiers qui
sont pas simples mais bon voilà c'est un
peu comme sur l'éducation
mais sont de vrais enjeux mais je pense
qu'il faut pas vous permettez bon
employé ça qu'il faut pas sabordé par
une hâte voilà donc voilà on n'a qu'un
conte à cinq ans voilà donc voilà il
nous faut travailler vite mais bien
donc le l'idée de l' ordonnance portant
ce prénom de protection reprenait tout
ça je pense que ça peut être intégré
justement à la réflexion sur la sur
cette justice spécialisée
s'agissant des familles monoparentales
donc je ne je ne rappelle pas peut-être
tout ce qui a été fait je vais juste
peut-être rappeler les éléments du
programme et donc il faudra mettre en
place un à création d'un droit opposable
à la garde d'enfant et puis d'extension
du mode de garde de 6 à 12 ans pour les
parents célibataires et une hausse de
l'allocation de soutien familial qui
passera de 116 100 174 euros voilà donc
effectivement c'est un sujet
qu'il faut voir enfin qu'il faudra oui
oui oui
oui alors ça c'est pas dans le programme
mais je note que je note je note je note
je me colle à la suggestion mona mais je
précise qu'elle n'est pas dans le
programme doc c'est une option pour
présenter par le sénat voilà
donc donc voilà pour ça
les s'agissant donc des filles dans les
filières scientifiques
vous suggérez peut-être d'avoir recours
à des mesures plus coercitives
je pense qu'il faut
je sais pas si j'irai honnêtement enfin
si
si j'irai forcément sur des mesures plus
coercitives à l'heure actuelle à l'heure
actuelle à l'heure actuelle de dire
qu'on a eue sur le au cours du précédent
quinquennat tout même je veux dire la
d'exp nicolas loi de décembre 2021 il y
avait eu la loi copé zimmermann
il ya une dizaine d'années
en revanche je pense que
là aussi il faut que nous travaillons
sur plein de lever de manière simultanée
pour justement avoir
en fait je n'emploie pas le terme de
viviez parce que je trouve qu'il est
vraiment horrible parce qu'on dirait
qu'il ya des petits poissons qui nagent
donc en fait c'est quand même c'est
quand même celui qui convient le mieux
donc c'est pour ça que je dis des
cercles qui doivent être élargi pour
permettre à davantage de femmes
d'accéder
à ces filières parce que en fait c'est
enfin je veux dire moi je je suis pas
fermé à la discussion à mais je n'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit forcément le
la meilleure des solutions parce qu'en
fait j'ai eu et j'ai pu déjà échangé
avec la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur la difficulté c'est vraiment
qu'il ya pas il n'ya pas les voilà c'est
ça voilà c'est que c'est qu'elles ne
sont pas là donc par exemple lors dans
l'ajustement dans la loi de décembre
2021 on a notamment la
le fait d'imposer 30 % de femmes dans
les jurys d'admission dans les cycles
supérieurs voilà c'est bien sûr que
c'est une mesure qui est incitative
esterra mais c'est vrai que ça me dit
l'ancien supérieur me dit mais le
problème c'est qu'il faut qu'on les hait
voilà donc enfin moi je ne suis fermé à
rien mais mais je pense que et peut-être
surviendrait après sur ce que vous dites
de l'orientation je pense aussi que là
nous avons à progresser là dessus
parce qu'en fait c'est vraiment à
presque à tous les âges et à plein de
niveaux qu'il faut que nous soyons
meilleurs
s'agissant de l'éducation à la vie
sexuelle et affective je pense que je
vous ai répondu s'agissant des questions
de
delà de madame
la sénatrice laurence cohen ben je donc
sur les tribunaux spécialisés je crois
que je vous ai à peu près répandu
sur les sur les filières de l'urgence je
vous connaissez très bien les chiffres
voilà ça m'ennuie un petit peu détaillé
parce qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai plus le je
suis ministre de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
néanmoins je peux quand même vous en
dire quelques mots un voilà c'est en
fait c'est vraiment un concept justement
de prise en charge spécifique justement
de ces un traitement judiciaire
spécifique de ces violences
de a à z c'est à dire il ya eu quatre
grandes thématiques qui ont été
commandés identifié dire le le début de
la procédure par exemple le dépôt de
plainte puis ensuite la manière dans les
affaires sont jugées les outils de
protection mises à disposition des
victimes des dispositifs de suivi dix
auteurs et puis un aspect qui est
concerne davantage tout ce qui est
coordination justement pilotage comité
de pilotage des états au sein des au
sein des juridictions et des items ont
été définies au sein de ses quatre
thématiques et que lorsque les
juridictions répondent à deux items dans
chacune des grandes 4 des grands des
quatre grandes thématiques et bien il a
été considéré qu'il y avait une filière
de l'urgent donc c'est vraiment un une
avancée importante et ce qu'ils montrent
aussi vraiment une prise en compte de ce
phénomène par le parler par
l'institution judiciaire par les
tribunaux une volonté politique
réaffirmée par le garde des sceaux eric
dupond moretti
donc voilà oui on a beaucoup progressé
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'on peut
penser que
des pôles deux juridictions spécialisées
permettrait d'avoir une réponse vraiment
très adapté justement à à ceux à ces
violences qui sont vraiment spécifique
je pense que je n'arrêterai jamais de
répéter que donner une claque à sa femme
ce n'est pas volé un cd dans un grand
magasin bien sûr le vol d' ac dc est
répréhensible mais ça ne m'interroge pas
la même manière le comportement le
l'esprit le psy le psy de son auteur
voilà donc
cette nécessité me paraît vraiment
devoir être retenu vous avez évoqué la
loi sur la prostitution
de 2016
alors là j'ai eu plusieurs choses vous
dis voilà
donc comme vous le comme vous le saviez
comme vous le savez donc une commission
départementales doit être mise en place
dans au niveau des préfectures
sur la lutte contre la prostitution à ce
jour donc
87 commission départementale ont été
installées dont cinquante et une
commission avec parcours de sortie
puisque vous ça vous souvenez donc il y
avait ces parcours de sortie qui sont
qui sont prévues l'epa courte sortie
donc permettent un meilleur
accompagnement des femmes sur leur t sur
le terrain pour leur sortie de la
prostitution au travers des parcours qui
leur sont proposés donc au 1er janvier
2022 une centaine d'associations ont été
agréées pour la mise en oeuvre du
parcours de sortie de la prostitution
446 parcours de sortie de la
prostitution ont été autorisés par
décision préfectorale
depuis 2010 7 790 personnes en
bénéficier d'un parcours sortie de
prostitution
s'agissant donc de la location
financière d'insertion sociale et
professionnelle qu'on appelle un fils
elle est d'un montant de 330 euros par
mois pour une personne seule est donc
cette allocation
est destiné à des personnes qui ne
peuvent bénéficier d'aucun minimum
social notamment lorsqu'elles ont été
débouté d'une demande d'asile est ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que l' enveloppe
allouée pour la première fois depuis a
augmenté justement pour la première fois
depuis sa création un million cinq deux
roues dans la programmation budgétaire
2022 est à noter aussi ce que je trouve
que c'est quand même assez intéressant
pour l'utilisation des deniers
c'est qu'un montant de 2 millions 6,2
millions six cent mille euros a été
dégagée des avoirs de la grâce que ça
m'aide agence de recouvrement des
amendes et notamment on peut imaginer
des condamnations pour proxénétisme et
c'est donc une somme de deux millions
six a pu être extraite de ceux de sept
de ses de ces fonds pour soutenir
justement des projets innovants de
prévention de la prostitution
et d'information contre le proxénétisme
et la traite des êtres humains et aussi
pour l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de prostitution et ou victimes
d'exploitation sexuelle
un petit mot aussi même si ce n'est pas
mon sujet parce que ça concerne les
mineurs mais ce à quoi sert la
prostitution et puis bon canton avant
d'être majeur au mineur
le gouvernement a lancé en novembre 2000
21 un plan interministériel doté de 14
millions d'euros pour mieux lutter
contre la prostitution des mineurs qui
concerne donc entre 7000 et dix mille
jeunes en france voilà ce que je les
éléments que je pouvais vous apporter
sur sur la prostitution et la loi
de 2016 rappelant tout de même que la
france a une position très forte en la
matière et qu'elle est quand même un des
seuls pays qui a adopté ce système
abolitionniste
[Musique]
voilà c'est ça vous avez abordé le sujet
de l'égalité salariale je pense que j'ai
dû un peu répondre déjà l'accès à la pma
pour toutes
alors le délai le délai trop long
notamment
juste tout de même pour pour vous
rappeler que un
investissement de 8 millions d'euros a
échelonné jusqu'en 2023 pour renforcer
les équipements et les moyens des cecos
les centres d'études et de conservation
des oeufs et du sperme humain
une première aide de trois millions 3 a
été consenti dès le premier semestre
2009 un t1
le gouvernement a bien conscience qu'une
des difficultés principales rencontrées
par l'écosystème des amp est celle de la
pénurie de dons de gamètes en france et
dans son gracieux
en outre la levée partielle de
l'anonymat des donneurs peut faire
craindre aussi un effet dissuasif
toutefois en angleterre dans une
situation similaire les dons ont d'abord
baisser avant de remonter un an et demi
plus tard avec un profil de donneurs
différents
donc pour essayer de
2,22 améliorer un cette situation une
campagne d'information et de
sensibilisation
autour du don de gamètes a été lancé par
l' agence de biomédecine le 21 octobre
2021 et cette campagne se divise en deux
volets un premier volet à destination
des donneurs potentiels et une seconde
sur le droit d'accès aux origines
en mai 2000 22 une campagne merci d'en
parler a été publiée pour donner la
parole à toutes les personnes concernées
par le don de gamètes
sur la sur la paix est mort sur la pema
avant donc la loi bioéthique donc la loi
limon qui simplifie l'adoption donc
cette loi du 21 février 2022 prévoit des
garanties concernant les cas spécifiques
que vous avez évoquées
afin d' à vous d'être pour permettre
d'adopter rapidement et d'adopter même
s'il ya une séparation avec la femme qui
a porté l'enfant donc en fait on il ya
un certain nombre de mesures j'allais
dire que correctrices si on peut dire
qu'ils ont pu être apportés par cette
loi du 21 février 2022 sur sur
l'adoption
sur le budget sur le budget alors je
sais que que comment dire c'est que
c'est toujours délicat de dire que en
fait c'est quand on cumule les
différentes tout ce qui est mis par tous
les ministères on aboutit à un budget
d'un milliard trois cents millions mais
c'est même une réalité
c'est un et c'est un ministère qu'elle a
une vocation interministérielle c'est un
ministère qui est délégué auprès de la
première ministre parce que justement
c'est une politique gouvernementale
c'est une politique transversale et donc
forcément
et bien chaque ministère participe voilà
cela dit moi je ne vous cache pas que
bien sûr
il ya des discussions budgétaires et que
j'espère pouvoir avoir une augmentation
malgré
j'allais dire les la rigueur budgétaire
mais
ce que je voulais dire c'est que ce que
je que je souhaiterais en revanche
améliorée c'est la meilleure visibilité
je pense qu'on peut encore et améliorer
cette visibilité justement de tous les
engagements de tous les ministères sur
ce sujet
sont des outils passé document de
politique transversale
ce sont des documents assez difficile
enfin j'ai pu le voir quand l'été au
ministère de la justice est assez
difficile à manier
à renseigner et donc je pense que nous
pouvons encore progresser mais ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que en fait une
poule si nous améliorons encore ces deux
document de politique transversale ce
sera plutôt pour montrer qu'on met plus
que ce qu'on pense même classe que ce
qui est aujourd'hui établi voilà donc un
milliard trois cents millions ce n'est
pas sous-estimer voilà c'est plutôt ce
ne serait pas su rester mais c'est
plutôt sous-estimée justement en
fonctionnement par rapport à la réalité
de ce qui est vraiment injecté par tous
les ministères
s'agissant des questions de madame la
sénatrice victoire jasmin
j'ai bien noté en ce que vous avez
indiquée sur sur la difficulté des
formations des femmes notamment parce
qu'on sait bien que ce sont les femmes
qui acceptent le moi aussi le célibat
géographique et on sait pourquoi 1 voilà
et quand il s'agit d'un célibat
géographique d'outre-mer vers la
métropole c'est encore autre chose que
quand il s'agit d'un célibat
géographique
entre nice et lyon ou nice et paris bien
sûr et j'entends bien et je pense que
c'est vraiment un point extrêmement
important et je le note pour en parler
aussi bien au ministre de la fonction
publique communiste de l'éducation
nationale parce que je pense
qu'effectivement il ya je pense que
c'est un c'est un peu du cousu main qui
font peut-être que que nous travaillons
justement pour
pour les territoires outre-mer sur ce
domaine de la formation
vous avez évoqué aussi l'association
amalgame
humaniste
j'en ai entendu beaucoup de bien
au sein de mon cabinet et voilà c'est
bien sûr
un bien sûr que je travaillerai
avec plaisir je dire avec cette
association est assez rapidement aussi
enfin en tout cas avant la fin de
l'année j'aimerais bien aussi pouvoir
effectuer un déplacement en outre-mer
aussi pour faire le point un peu sur les
différentes problématiques tout en étant
consciente également que chaque
territoire a sa propre spécificité bien
sûr
s'agissant de la question de madame la
sénatrice
micheline jacques
ci va voilà faisait de la voilà sur les
sur les enfants exposés aux violences au
sein du couple je pense que
un des sujets qui a émergé justement
lors du grenelle des violences
conjugales et c'est vraiment je pense le
l'impact des violences au sein du couple
l'impact dévastateur des violences au
sein du couple sur les enfants et
ça a donné lieu
à différentes modifications législatives
je parlais reprendre mais en ce qui
concerne notamment l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale
la suspension
de plein droit d'exercice de l'autorité
parentale en cas de poursuites pour
homicide volontaire aux tentatives
d'homicides d'un
de l'autre parent voilà et puis aussi la
possibilité de statuer sur l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale donné au juge pénal
c'est aussi
il y a aussi des avancées c'est par
exemple décret du 23 novembre 2000
maintien qui reconnaît à l'enfant
justement exposés aux violences au sein
du couple le statut de victimes c'est un
d'une avancée importante
et puis une circulaire alors
permettez-moi de pas vous donner la date
exacte parce que si on février 2022
c'est le circulaire du garde des sceaux
de février 2022 qui tend justement à qui
tend à généraliser le dispositif
de prise en charge des enfants présents
lors d'un féminicide si ce qu'on appelle
le protocole féminicide qui avait été
mise en place en seine-saint-denis
justement pour une généralisation c'est
à dire qu'on prend soin justement de ses
enfants lors les examinant les
hospitaliser dans le cas échéant
justement pour les accompagner le mieux
possible
voilà un moment particulièrement
douloureux pour eux
s'agissant de la question de madame la
sénatrice lana tetuanui de polynésie
donc j'ai bien entendu votre
votre préoccupation aussi finalement
d'une justice vendent un tribunal que
vous souhaiteriez aussi dédier un jeu le
temps que je pense qu'on revient un peu
au sujet de des pôles de jeunes éditions
spécialisé
vous avez
vous avez aussi évoqué la promotion des
femmes dans le corps préfectoral
voilà je pense que c'est un sujet que je
peux évoquer avec le ministre
effectivement de l'outre-mer
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
simple et
c'est vrai que vos territoires et son
loi
et
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il faut
certainement peut-être aussi inciter
davantage peut-être les mais c'est parce
que c'est vraiment un sujet qui est
qu'il faut évoquer justement avec avec
le ministre au tonnerre peut-être aussi
le ministre de la fonction publique
voilà en tout cas qu'il s'agisse du
corps préfectoral comme des formations
vos différentes interventions montre
bien qu'il y a justement un travail à
mener en ce sens là avec les différents
ministères
je pense que j'ai répondu non non non
mais non marie pierre monnier qui était
en visite au dock sur la ruralité non en
plus c'est un sujet
très très important
alors j'ai bien entendu évidemment votre
rapport
votre rapport donc
voilà c'est sa femme ait vu réalité
il est très riche moi ce que je sais ce
que j'aimerais vous proposez c'est que
nous puissions peut-être
avoir un échange avec les différends
avec les différents rapporteurs mais ce
que je vous
ai ce que je vous dis ce que je vous
propose c'est peut-être d'avoir un
échange sur la circonscription plutôt
que de la voir
plutôt que de la voir à mon ministère de
la voir dans la circonscription dans des
cours à porter
voilà parce qu'en fait c'est aussi un
signe qui serait donnée justement à
cette question de la ruralité
j'ai et justement quand nous nous quand
nous évoquerons votre rapport nous
pourrons aussi révoqué le sujet dont
vous avez parlé c'est à dire de la
possibilité de le désigner un référent
égalité dans les communes ou
intercommunalités
voilà je pense que un peu de la même
manière que lorsque nous aborderons les
conclusions du rapport sur la
pornographie lorsque nous nous
échangerons sur le rapport sur la
ruralité nous pourrons envisager les
voix que nous pouvons
explorer ensemble puis des pistes qui
peuvent se dégager et qui paraissent
possible aussi
à suivre j'ai noté aussi votre petite
réserve par rapport aux appels à projets
je l'entends bourg néanmoins là il y en
avait un qui avait été lancée
dernièrement et justement donc qui
portait sur 1 qui portait d'ailleurs sur
une somme d'un million d'euros
et nous allons d'ailleurs
annoncé les lauréats dans les jours qui
viennent donc j'entends néanmoins votre
votre réserve par rapport à ces appels à
projets et je pense qu'effectivement
nous nous devrons peut-être davantage
vigilant
de faire et faire en sorte que aussi des
les subventions puisse être peut-être
davantage discuter même si je pense que
les appels à projets sont très
pertinents davantage de discuter peut
être au niveau des départements des
régions notre notamment via nos délais
liés régionale aux droits des femmes
voilà
j'espère avoir répondu
en bonne partie à vos questions je vous
remercie vraiment de votre écoute de
votre bienveillance et je reste à votre
disposition et je pense que nous avons
déjà pris date pour un certain nombre de
rendez vous bah écoutez madame la
ministre je vous remercie parce que
l'exercice n'était pas simple il ya eu
beaucoup d'interventions beaucoup de
questions et nous comprenons bien que
dans la mesure où les arbitrages ne sont
pas encore effectué vous n'avez pas pu
répondre à toutes les questions mais les
sénateurs et sénatrices vous adresserons
probablement des demandes aussi
individuel puisque vous avez une équipe
aussi autour de vous comme je disais
dans mon propos liminaire qu'on connaît
en partie est et qu'on s'est extrêmement
réactive je voudrais vous remercier pour
d'ailleurs marie pierre monnier qui nous
écoutent toujours depuis le travaux
remercie sincèrement pour les uns
pensent que vous lui avait apporté elle
me demandait de le faire donc je le fais
avec plaisir je lui souhaite bon voyage
par la même occasion et donc je vous
dire que nous avons acté déjà trois
rendez vous avec vous voir quatre en
réalité le rendez-vous bien entendu avec
les rapporteurs laurence que rossignol
qui est là sur lorsque nous allons
rendre publiques nos travaux qui sur
l'industrie de la pornographie avec
laurence cohen laurence rossignol et
alexandra burke fontan et moi même le
rendez vous que nous allons calais
puisque nous étions hier soir j'étais
avec les deux rapporteurs martine
filleul et dominique vernay qui nous a
rejoints lorsque nous avons présenté la
volonté d'avancer encore plus loin sur
les travaux qu'on me dise verra porter
sur la parité dans dans la haute
fonction publique avec le bilan des dix
ans de la loi sauvadet et donc les
propositions les douze propositions qui
sont faites donc on viendra vous les
présenter peut-être après une trêve
estivale j'imagine voilà que femme et
ruralité il y avait huit rapporteurs
issus de tous les groupes politiques
nous viendrons à la rentrée vous
présenter nos travaux et bien entendu en
tant que présidente je vous invite
fortement à venir et rapporteur dans le
département de la vendée pour présenter
ce rapport excusez moi chers collègues
rapporteur
non mais le premier qui dégaine à raison
en rallye terre voilà et au final vous
dire que on a eu trois interventions des
territoires ultramarins
on sort d'une période électorale
compliqué et de la vie parlementaire est
devenue différente aussi et on a vu ce
vote dans les territoires ultramarins
nous avons des sénateurs et sénatrices
au sénat très engagé sur ces territoires
sur leur territoire qui ont des
particularités et votre jeu je pense
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à travailler et
à démontrer sur place aussi même à des
milliers de kilomètres notre engagement
sur ces sujets vous dire que nous vous
souhaitons aussi au nom de la délégation
pleine réussite dans vos missions nous
avons compris au travers dé vos réponses
que vous étiez pleinement engagés que
vous aviez la volonté de faire avancer
des des sujets des sujets qui nous
tiennent à coeur nous pour l'égalité
pour la mixité pour la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales
intrafamiliales je vous souhaite surtout
en réalité madame la ministre de réussir
à gagner tous les arbitrages que vous
aurez à gagner pour mettre en place tout
ce que vous souhaitez en mettre en place
avec beaucoup de sincérité et beaucoup
de pugnacité
donc merci déjà pour cette feuille de
route en partie décidé vous ne trouverez
nous la délégation aux droits des femmes
pour avancer sur ces sujets et s'il faut
vous aider pour obtenir ses arbitrages
nous viendrons également vous épauler
parce que la difficulté sera là le dès
qu'on parle d'eux par exemple médecine
légale pour lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales
il faut des moyens pour la justice
lorsqu'on parle d'éducation à la
sexualité il faut des personnes en face
des élèves donc on le voit bien il va
falloir défendre les dossiers auprès des
financiers ceux qui tiennent les cordons
de la bourse du gouvernement
voilà donc pleine réussite dans vos
missions madame la ministre et vous
trouverez toujours la délégation et ses
membres à vos côtés merci merci à vous
merci